à
[Musique]
l'ambiance dès le début de la journée
était plutôt les airs et bon enfant
malgré la raison pour laquelle la
communauté s'est rassemblé plusieurs
centaines de personnes ont tenu à se
déplacer ici pour rendre hommage non
seulement aux 215 enfants dont les
restes ont été découverts juste à côté
mais à leurs familles et aux survivants
de tous les pensionnats race alcoy est
porteuse de quel humain et elle était
sur le site avant même le lever du
soleil à cinq heures bien auparavant que
les médias sont les rues mais on était
là vraiment pour prier pour des enfants
d'ici et ailleurs pour vraiment leur
envoyer
avec les anciennes
laisser aller ses enfants morts elle est
célébrée avec des enfants bien vivant
d'aujourd'hui c'est un geste
traditionnel pourrait aider à la
guérison
et ce qui aide aussi celle onde de choc
qui a provoqué la découverte des corps
des enfants de kamloops et celle des
centaines d'autres enfants partout au
pays
nanjing
chine au mali
oui non et ce code fait le secret
dévoilé de nombreuses personnes en
parler pendant cette journée de
réflexion même la gouverneure-générale
et sur d'autres appareils comme des
relents parfois les pipots non
un nom et se transforme deux communautés
entre les rires les et enfants et la
musique parfois caustique il ya
évidemment on est là
parce que la souffrance qu est vive un
an plus tard
journée d'aujourd'hui pour que la
communauté se tient et s'entraîne et
avec m constitue canada il ya espoir
qu'il puisse un jour or si ses blessures
c'est julie landry radio tara tari
camelous